I think that guy was cheating cuz didn't
R bomb has been
planted terrorists
win Counter-Strike 2's cheating problem
is getting out of control you simply
cannot play the game without running
into opponents or your own teammates who
are blatantly hacking at the same time
the game has also seen its biggest
player drop since release and valve has
been radio silent so is Counter-Strike 2
actually dying and are cheaters
responsible the number one and the
number two are not even playing anymore
they just play one game a week to not
lose to to inactivity that's crazy bro
disgusting
bro all right folks before we get into
it we have a second merch drop take a
look guess what folks our touch grass
hoodies did so well that the suits are
actually letting us make even more dumb
gamer inspired like our new Bader
zip up hoodies made for all the real
blue collar workers out there perfect
for any environment whether it's
catching fish hanging your teammates out
to dry or just tugging on your or how
about our inspiring new onward and
forward tea the ideal shirt for the
sweatiest of Gamers so that you can slam
the W key with zero resistance and
little to no chafing teammates don't
like it them ruin everyone's night
oh and yeah we got these blue Esports
te's I forgot we made these uh yeah
they're definitely blue and they say
sports game in style and comfort with
the score Esports drop 2 available now
if you like the look at that check the
link in the description below all right
so I have been one of the more outspoken
Defenders of the current state of CS2
and I still believe that valve is
updating the game at a rate we have not
really seen from a developer before but
as of last week I've taken a break and
it's not because the movement feels bad
or the audio is inconsistent or that we
still don't have cash I stopped playing
because every other match I was in had
at least one full rage cheater in it I
stopped playing because I wasn't having
fun anymore the question is am I the
only one over the last 2 months
Counter-Strike 2's player count has
dropped by over 20% and many are
sounding the alarm that the game is
already dying but is it actually or is
this just the natural stabilization
after the hype of the release has died
down the truth is it's probably a bit of
both so let's investigate when we look
at the community's issues with the game
there are pretty much three camps those
complaining about performance those
complaining about cheaters and those who
take issue with both now honestly when
it comes to the first Camp I don't think
they make up that significant of a
portion of the audience to have that big
of an effect on the player count they
are extremely outspoken online and we
have started to see Pros like twist give
concrete examples of the problems
they're facing but these are pros and
players who dedicate a lot of time if
not their whole lives to playing this
game semi-casual players who make up the
base of the game's audience aren't
really going to notice all of the
intricacies and inconsistencies of subti
now that doesn't mean that these issues
aren't important they are very much real
and as people like launders pointed out
the feel of Counter-Strike is what makes
the game so special and not fixing it
will have its consequences but if you're
the average player not being able to hit
a jump or dying to bad interp is a bit
of an invisible issue that's not going
to be a detriment to your overall
enjoyment do you know what is a clear
detent to everyone cheaters not everyone
knows how CS is supposed to feel but
everyone knows what it feels like to die
to a cheater have it happen enough and
you're going to get fed up and it's not
crazy to point out just how bad things
are if you look up the words cheaters or
cheating online people are either live
streaming themselves hacking showing off
the best software or complaining about
how many people are hacking it's gotten
to the point where the community is now
pleading for an invasive anti-che people
love this game soing much and are so
sick and tired of cheaters that they are
willing to give valve 24-hour access to
her godamn PCS we cannot allow people to
come in from valerin from pubg from Call
of Duty from anywhere and the first
experience they have with Counter-Strike
2 is a bunch ofing idiots teating their
ass off we are opening more than 30
million cases a month we're generating a
revenue that is absolutely absurd and
the only thing literally the only thing
I want to ask for you right now is to
fix the goddamn entity anyone who has
played the game knows that it's an issue
back is straight up not working or not
even on and if it is it's flat out
unacceptable and even embarrassing and
all of this frustration is just
highlighted by the fact that valve isn't
saying about it listen it's
obviously in their best interest to be
secretive about anti-che but it feels
like saying nothing is even worse listen
valve did do a pretty rare interview
with PC Gamer and we're pretty candid
about the current state of
Counter-Strike 2 they spoke about sub
tick why they seemingly released the
game earlier than it should have and
even the potential for new weapons but
you know what they didn't mention once
anti-che and I honestly wouldn't be
surprised if they told PC Gamer that
they wouldn't be Fielding any questions
about it now is Counter-Strike 2 dying
because of it well I for one have
stopped playing and although I'm not
Global a lot of my career revolves
around playing this game and I just
can't take it anymore is a chunk of that
20% drop in the same boat as me it's
possible but others have pointed out
that losing players is a natural thing
after a game's release as Vu pointed out
on Twitter csgo saw an even bigger
player drop a month after its launch and
even joked about the fact that people
complaining are the same people who play
the game like 6 hours a day so maybe the
current player count is right where it
should be CS 2's release was the second
coming of Christ but I doubt they were
going to be able to maintain 1.7 million
players every single day maybe things
will jump back up whenever new content
or updates roll out and then just dip
down again but even if this is the case
is that actually okay some of the people
leaving might might be doing it because
of cheaters but it's not like those who
stay are suddenly okay with it everyone
has their limit listen the drop in
players is due to a number of reasons
some are completely out of valves
control and some are even natural but
one thing that is in valves control is
people leaving because of cheaters and
if they don't address it is CS2 dying
won't be a question anymore but a
fact listen there's only one way that we
can know the true answer if people are
leaving because of cheaters or not and
it's with our community so I want to see
in the comments yay or nay yay I'm
leaving because of cheaters nay I have
not left because of cheaters or I have
not left at all and that will be the
true definitive answer and we'll send it
to valve and they'll fix the issue I
know it